GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. WE ARE
WAITING FOR OUR MEMBERS TO JOIN.
THEY ARE IN THE BUILDING AND
AROUND. SO WE'RE GOING TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE THIS MORNING.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO IS
WITH US. PLEASE STEP FORWARD. WE
ONLY HAVE TWO ITEMS. THERE'S NO
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY, FIRST
ITEM IS AB 224. MISS RUBIO,
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS. I'M
PROUD TO JOIN SENATOR UMBERG IN
OFFERING AB 224, WHICH WOULD
EXTEND THE NEWS CARRIER
EXEMPTION FROM AB FIVE UNTIL
2030. I'M THANKFUL FOR OUR
FORMER ASSEMBLY LABOR CHAIR FOR
HIS MOST RECENT EFFORTS, WHICH
THIS MEASURE IS SIMPLY AN
EXTENSION OF NEWSPAPER'S FULFILL
A CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR DEMOCRACY
AND WE CANNOT SURVIVE WITHOUT A
ROBUST FOURTH ESTATE. THIS ROLE
IS AMPLIFIED GIVEN THE
PROLIFERATION OF MYTHS AND
DISINFORMATION CURRENTLY
PLAGUING MEDIA. THE COMMUNITIES
THAT RELY ON PRINT PUBLICATIONS
CANNOT AFFORD TO BE OVERLOOKED.
AT A TIME WHEN OUR DEMOCRACY
LIES IN THE BALANCE. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY RELEVANT TO ME AS MY
85 YEAR, 84 YEAR OLD FATHER GETS
HIS PRINT SUBSCRIPTION OF LA
OPINION EVERY SINGLE DAY. HIS
PERSONAL ACCESS TO NEWS MEDIA IS
NOT UNIQUE, AS COUNTLESS
COMMUNITY PUBLICATIONS OFTEN
SERVING EXCLUSIVELY ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES, WOULD NOT SURVIVE
WITHOUT THIS EXTENSION. THE
NEWSPAPER PROFESSION CONTINUES
TO FACE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
RESULTING FROM LOSS OF AD
REVENUE TO TECH GIANTS WHILE
TRANSITIONING TO DIGITAL
PLATFORMS, AND A DECLINE IN
SUBSCRIPTIONS. THESE REASONS
COMPOUND WITH COMPOUNDED WITH
THE UNIQUE STRUCTURE IN WHICH
CARRIERS CONTRACT WITH MULTIPLE
PUBLISHERS, PLACES STRESSES ON
THE INDUSTRY, WHICH IS NOT SEEN
ELSEWHERE, AND THAT IS WHY WE
ARE HERE TODAY. DESPITE THIS,
THE INDUSTRY IS MAKING
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN
TRANSITIONING COMPLETELY TO
DIGITAL NEWSPAPERS, CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL INFORMATION ON
ISSUES RANGING FROM LOCAL TO
INTERNATIONAL, AND OFTEN THEY
ARE THE SOLE SOURCE OF
INFORMATION FOR MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, WHICH IS THE CASE
FOR MY FATHER. BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THIS
TRANSITION, JOBS FOR
JOURNALISTS, JOURNALISTS,
EDITORS AND NEWS NEWS PRODUCTION
WORKERS WILL BE PROTECTED WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY SUPPORTING THE
CURRENT AGE OF NEWS MEDIA. WITH
ME TODAY, I HAVE BRITTNEY
BARSOTTI ON BEHALF OF OUR
SPONSOR, THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION, AS WELL
AS COLLEEN NELSON, EXECUTIVE
EDITOR OF THE SACRAMENTO BEE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MISS
RUBIO. AND BEFORE YOUR WITNESSES
COME, WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WHILE WE CAN. ASSISTANT,
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE?
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE. WILK.
PRESENT WILK. PRESENT. CORTEZ.
DURAZO LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD. HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO, WITNESSES, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD, OR YOU CAN USE THE
PODIUM. IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
SEATS HERE, YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M COLLEEN MCCAIN
NELSON AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
EDITOR OF THE SACRAMENTO BEE AND
MCCLATCHY'S REGIONAL EDITOR FOR
OUR CALIFORNIA NEWSROOMS,
INCLUDING THE FRESNO BEE, THE
MODESTO BEE, THE SAN LUIS OBISPO
TRIBUNE, AND THE MERCED
SUN-STAR. I'M ALSO PROUD TO
SERVE AS A DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. WE TAKE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS THE FOURTH
ESTATE VERY SERIOUSLY, AND MY
FOCUS IS SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES
BY PROVIDING FACT BASED
JOURNALISM. SO APPEARING BEFORE
YOU IN SUPPORT OF LEGISLATION IS
EXTREMELY RARE AND UNDERSCORES
HOW CRITICAL THIS EXTENSION IS
TO THE FUTURE OF LOCAL NEWS.
MCCLATCHY CONTRACTS WITH
DISTRIBUTION COMPANIES THAT WORK
WITH INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS TO
DELIVER OUR PUBLICATIONS. MOST
OF THOSE CARRIERS DISTRIBUTE
MULTIPLE PUBLICATIONS AT THE
SAME TIME. CONSIDER YOUR
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES IN THE
CAPITOL. MANY OF YOU RECEIVE THE
SACRAMENTO BEE, THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE, THE LA
TIMES, AND YOUR HOMETOWN PAPERS.
ONE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR CAN
DELIVER ALL OF THOSE
PUBLICATIONS. BUT WHICH NEWS
OUTLET WOULD EMPLOY THEM WITHOUT
AN EXTENSION OF THE NEWSPAPER
CARRIER EXEMPTION, THEY WOULD BE
PAID LESS TO DISTRIBUTE A SINGLE
PUBLICATION. AS AN EMPLOYEE AT
MCCLATCHY PRINT IS NOT THE
FUTURE. ONLINE READERS NOW FAR
OUTNUMBER PRINT READERS. OUR
NEWSROOMS ARE FOCUSED ON
CREATING A SUSTAINABLE DIGITAL
BUSINESS MODEL, BUT IT'S A WORK
IN PROGRESS. OUR NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN A CRITICAL
PERIOD OF TRANSITION. PRINTING
NEWSPAPERS HAS BECOME COST
PROHIBITIVE, SO WE ARE FOCUSED
ON GROWING NEW REVENUE SOURCES,
INCLUDING DIGITAL SUBSCRIPTIONS,
DIGITAL ADVERTISING AND
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDING. WE'VE
ALREADY REDUCED OUR PRINT
DISTRIBUTION AND HAVE MOVED TO
MAIL DELIVERY IN FRESNO, MODESTO,
MERCED AND SAN LUIS OBISPO. WE
CAN SEE THE DAY WHEN WE WILL BE
COMPLETELY DIGITAL ON THE
HORIZON, BUT IF WE MOVE TOO
QUICKLY, WE RISK LOSING THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THIS TRANSITION
IN A WAY THAT IS SUSTAINABLE. AT
A MOMENT WHEN NEWSPAPERS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN EVERY WEEK, THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE THE
RUNWAY TO STAND UP A NEW LONG
TERM BUSINESS MODEL. THIS
EXTENSION WILL ENSURE THAT LOCAL
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS CAN COMPLETE
OUR DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION,
WHILE CONTINUING TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WITH
LOCAL NEWS, I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 224. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, BRITTANY
BARSOTTI. I SERVE AS THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB 224, I
BELIEVE MISS NELSON AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO DID A GREAT JOB OF
LAYING OUT WHERE THE INDUSTRY IS
AT, THAT WE ARE IN A PERIOD OF
TRANSITION AND AS PRINT HAS
DECREASED, SO HAVE PRINTING
PLACES. FOR EXAMPLE, IN FREMONT,
IN THE BAY AREA, THERE ARE 12
DIFFERENT DAILIES PRINTED AT ONE
FACILITY, AND SO YOU HAVE
DISTRIBUTORS GOING TO ONE STOP
TO BE ABLE TO GET THE MULTIPLE
PUBLICATIONS THEY DELIVER AND
THEN HANDLING THEIR DISTRIBUTION
AND WITH THIS OVERLAP, IT DOES
CREATE THE CONCERN OF WHO YOU
WOULD BE AN EMPLOYEE OF AND
MAKES THE BUSINESS MODEL
SOMEWHAT INCONSISTENT WITH AB
FIVE. AND SO, AS WE CONTINUE TO
SEE AN INCREASE IN MAIL
DISTRIBUTION AND OTHER OPTIONS,
THE NEED FOR CARRIERS WILL
SLOWLY DISSIPATE. AND ALSO, WE
ARE ONE OF TWO CATEGORIES OF
WORKERS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE ORIGINAL ROUND OF EXEMPTIONS
THAT HAVE NOT HAD THAT CONVERTED
TO A PERMANENT EXEMPTION. AND,
YOU KNOW, WITH THE LAST EXAMPLE,
WE WORKED REALLY CLOSELY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, WHO WAS
THEN THE CHAIR OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE, TO ENSURE THAT THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS INCLUDED
WHAT WAS IMPORTANT TO THE
VARIOUS LABOR STAKEHOLDERS AND
HAVE DONE OUR BEST TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE BEING FULFILLED
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. SO THANK
YOU, AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 224. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE HERE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? PLEASE STEP FORWARD,
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. PLEASE STEP TO THE
PODIUM OR HAVE A SEAT WHEREVER
YOU WANT YOUR PODIUM. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SARAH FLAX, I'M FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
AND WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. BUT WHAT WE DO AGREE
WITH IS THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
NEWS INDUSTRY AND PRESERVING
LOCAL NEWS THAT WE CAN AGREE ON,
WE REPRESENT JOURNALISTS AND WE
HAVE FOUGHT FOR MAKING SURE THAT
WE GET MONEY INTO THE INDUSTRY
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT ROLE.
BUT WHAT WE DO OPPOSE IS
PROPPING UP AN INDUSTRY ON THE
BACKS OF WORKERS, ESPECIALLY THE
LOWEST PAID AND MOST VULNERABLE
WORKERS. NEWSPAPER DELIVERY
PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE THAT YOU SEE
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD AT 5 A.M,
DRIVING AROUND ARE NOT THE CAUSE
OF THE DECLINE IN THE NEWS
INDUSTRY. WE CAN LOOK AT TECH
GIANTS LIKE GOOGLE, LIKE META,
LIKE OTHER HUGE ENTITIES THAT
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE DECLINE.
YET THEY GET TO CONTRIBUTE
POCKET CHANGE TO A FUND THAT
THEY GET A TAX DEDUCTION ON AND
GET OUT OF ANY KIND OF TAXES.
AND REGULATIONS. YET THE WORKERS
WHO ARE DELIVERING NEWSPAPERS,
WHO ARE THE BACKBONE OF GETTING
THIS INFORMATION INTO
COMMUNITIES, WE'RE EXEMPTING
THEM FROM A LAW THAT REQUIRES
THAT THEY BE PAID MINIMUM WAGE,
PAID SICK DAYS, WORKERS COMP
REIMBURSEMENT FOR GAS REPAIRS ON
THEIR CARS, EVERYTHING THAT
WORKERS NEED, ESPECIALLY THE
LOWEST PAID WORKERS. THIS WAS
ORIGINALLY A TEMPORARY EXEMPTION
FROM THE LAW BECAUSE THE
INDUSTRY SAID THEY WERE
TRANSITIONING. IT'S BEEN WHAT,
FOUR YEARS? FIVE YEARS? THEY'RE
ASKING FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS TO
WHAT I HEARD WAS REPLACED
DELIVERY WORKERS WITH A NEW
FORM. SO BASICALLY WORKERS ARE
GOING TO BE MISCLASSIFIED, NOT
GET THE RIGHTS, THE BENEFITS AND
THE WAGES THAT THEY DESERVE
UNTIL THE INDUSTRY DECIDES TO
GET RID OF THEM OR FINDS A WAY
TO BE ABLE TO GET RID OF THEM,
THE OTHER THING IS, IS THAT THEY
SAID THAT THE BUSINESS MODEL
DOESN'T WORK, EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE EXEMPTED FROM AB5.
NEWSPAPER DELIVERY IS STILL
UNDER THE BORELLO TEST, WHICH IS
NOT AS STRONG OF A TEST, BUT IT
IS A TEST FOR MISCLASSIFICATION.
IN THE PAST 15 YEARS, THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF CASES WHERE
THESE WORKERS WERE FOUND TO BE
EMPLOYEES, EVEN UNDER THE
BORELLO TEST. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE HERE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL? PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. GOOD MORNING, NAVNEET
PERRIER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION, WE'RE REGRETFULLY
IN OPPOSITION. LIKE MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS, THESE EMPLOYEES ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THEY'RE LOW
WAGE WORKERS, AND THEY DESERVE
TO BE PROTECTED FROM
EXPLOITATION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE SEEING NONE,
WE'LL MOVE TO THE MEMBERS,
MEMBERS? SURE. I'LL KICK IT OFF.
FIRST OF ALL, I LOVE NEWSPAPERS.
I KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO GO AWAY
SOMEDAY, BUT I'M VERY UPSET
ABOUT THAT. AND YOU KNOW, THEY
TALKED ABOUT THE MODEL. AND THE
MODEL IS. RIGHT. SO I GET MY
COMMUNITY NEWSPAPER AND I GET
THE L.A. TIMES, SAME PERSON
DELIVERS BOTH OF THEM. THAT
WOULD DOUBLE THE COST OF THE
NEWSPAPER COMPANY, RIGHT? IF
THEY HAD TO SEPARATE THAT. SO TO
ME, IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW,
SYNERGY. AND IT MAKES A WHOLE
LOT OF SENSE. AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO DO TO PROTECT THESE
EMPLOYERS. THE LABOR ADVOCATE,
THE LABOR ADVOCATE WANTS TO PUT
THOSE EMPLOYEES OUT OF BUSINESS.
SO THAT JUST MAKES NO SENSE TO
ME. SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY AND I WILL MOVE IT. I
GUESS IT'S APPROPRIATE NOW. I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. ANYONE ELSE?
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS, YOU KNOW,
COMING FROM LABOR, THIS IS A
TOUGH BILL FOR ME. BUT I ALSO
SPENT YEARS WORKING IN THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY. AND TO BE
QUITE FRANKLY, THIS WAS ALWAYS
THE WORST JOB, IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND I WANT TO SEE US WORK ON
WAYS TO HAVE A JUST TRANSITION
FOR THESE WORKERS BECAUSE, THE
REASON WHY I'M NOT IN JOURNALISM
TODAY IS BECAUSE IT KEEPS
COLLAPSING AND COLLAPSING AND
COLLAPSING ON TOP OF THE
WORKERS, AND THERE REALLY ISN'T
A STRATEGY ON HOW TO RAISE
STANDARDS AND INTEGRATE INTO A
LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR, FOR
THESE WORKERS, YOU KNOW, I,
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A TIME
BOUND EXEMPTION, THAT IT DOES
HAVE A SUNSET. AND WE KNOW THERE
ARE SO MANY BILLS IN THIS
BUILDING TODAY THAT ARE FOCUSING
ON WAYS TO ADDRESS, THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY AND TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS AND HOPEFULLY
KEEP A FREE PRESS. AND I
APPRECIATED THE FACT BASED
JOURNALISM THAT WE RELY ON, AND
PARTICULARLY IN OUR ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES. WHERE THESE ARE THE
PAPERS THAT HELP KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES INFORMED. SO, I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR MOVING THIS
FORWARD, AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER ON A FUTURE BILL
THAT FIGURES OUT A JUST
TRANSITION. AND SO NOW I WILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? AND
THEN I'LL HAVE THE ASSISTANT.
THANK YOU. AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS. AND I KNOW THIS IS A
VERY DIFFICULT BILL. IT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN, BUT TO THE POINT
THAT I WAS TRYING TO MAKE
EARLIER IN REGARDS TO MY FATHER,
A LOT OF THE ETHNIC COMMUNITIES
DEPEND ON THE NEWSPAPERS AND NOT
JUST THE ETHNIC COMMUNITIES, BUT
THE OLDER POPULATION THAT THAT
IS USED TO GETTING THEIR PRINT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW, MY
FATHER DOESN'T NAVIGATE GOOGLE
OR ANY OF THE OTHER PLATFORMS TO
TRY AND GET THEIR MAIL. AND SO
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY TO FIND A
TRANSITION TO THIS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE NEWSPAPER
COMPANIES, THEY'RE CAUGHT IN
BETWEEN AT THE MOMENT. BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND OTHERS TO SEE
IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO,
MAKE, YOU KNOW, OUR NEWSPAPERS
MORE SUSTAINABLE. I HAVE TO TELL
YOU, I STILL LIKE TO THE SMELL
OF THE PAPER IN THE MORNING AND
YOU KNOW, AND I KNOW THAT NOT,
YOU KNOW, OUR YOUNGER GENERATION
IS NOT USED TO THAT. BUT WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU, WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WILKES. WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL ASSISTANT ON
FINAL ITEM 1AB, 224. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILK
WILK I CORTEZ. Â CORTEZ I
DURAZO. LAIRD. LAIRD I THANK YOU
ON CALL. CAN YOU HEAR ME? OKAY.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL WITH A VOTE
OF 4 TO 0. OKAY. YEAH. WHAT IS
THAT? OKAY. NEXT UP, 1034,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. HOW ARE
YOU? GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. AB 1034 WOULD EXTEND
THE EXEMPTION. SUNSET SUNSET
DATE FOR LAWSUITS ORIGINATED
UNDER THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S ACT. WE KNOW AS PAGA
FOR CONTRACTORS IN THE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES THAT ARE
PARTY TO A VALID COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT, ALSO KNOWN
AS CBA. MEETING SPECIFIED
CRITERIA AND HAVING NEGOTIATED
WITH THEIR LOCAL UNION TO
INCLUDE THE WAIVER IN THEIR CBA.
THE STATUTE DOES NOT ALTER A
LOCAL UNION'S ABILITY TO DECIDE
TO INCLUDE OR NOT INCLUDE THE
PAGA WAIVER IN THEIR CBA,
INCLUDING THE WAIVER WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE A SUBJECT OF
BARGAINING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BY
EACH UNION. WHEN A LABOR UNION
AND AN EMPLOYER IN THE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES ENTER
INTO A VALID COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT, EXISTING
LAW PROVIDES THAT THOSE
EMPLOYERS SHALL BE EXEMPT FROM
PAGA CLAIMS, PROVIDED THE CBA
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING. PREMIUM
WAGE RATES FOR OVERTIME AN
HOURLY WAGE OF NOT LESS THAN
30%, MORE THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE,
A GRIEVANCE AND BINDING
ARBITRATION PROCEDURE TO REDRESS
VIOLATIONS. A CLEAR WAIVER OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF PAGA IN
UNAMBIGUOUS TERMS. AUTHORIZATION
FOR THE ARBITRATOR TO AWARD ANY
AND ALL REMEDIES AVAILABLE UNDER
PAGA. SECTION 203D OF THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT RELATIONS ACT AFFIRMS
THAT RESOLVING LABOR DISPUTES
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS IS THE DESIRABLE
METHOD FOR SETTLING GRIEVANCE
DISPUTES RELATED TO THE
APPLICATION OR THE
INTERPRETATION OF AN EXISTING
CBA. SO THIS BILL ALIGNS WITH
CONGRESSIONAL INTENT BY USING
THE WELL-ESTABLISHED COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES IN LIEU OF PAGA. SO HB
1034 WILL ALLOW WORKERS TO
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
IMPORTANT EXEMPTION BY EXTENDING
THE CURRENT SUNSET IN THE LAW
FROM 2028 TO 2038. THE MEASURE
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
AND THE STATE COUNCIL OF LABORS,
AMONG MANY OTHERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME COMES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. YOU MAY PROCEED. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, EDDIE
BERNACCHI, ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION, WHICH REPRESENTS 15
CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND OVER 2000 UNION SIGNATORY
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA, YOU KNOW, THE AUTHOR
DID AN ELOQUENT JOB OF GOING
THROUGH THE NEED FOR THE BILL.
BUT I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
THINGS. THIS IS A SIMPLE SUNSET,
BUT IT'S A CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
TO THE SIGNATORY CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. THIS POLICY IS SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US
BECAUSE UNION SIGNATORY
CONTRACTORS NEED THE
EFFICIENCIES IN OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS THAT ALLOW
US TO COMPETE IN THE
MARKETPLACE, WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING PREMIUM WAGES AND
ROBUST HEALTH AND PENSION
BENEFITS TO OUR WORKERS.
CONVERSELY, WITHOUT THE WAIVER
LIKE THIS PAGA WAIVER AND OTHER
CBA EFFICIENCIES, UNION
SIGNATORY CONTRACTORS CAN FACE A
DOUBLE JEOPARDY AS THEY MUST
WORK THROUGH THE CBA GRIEVANCE
PROCEDURE WHILE ALSO BEING
SUBJECT TO LAWSUITS AT THE SAME
TIME, WHICH PLACES THEM AT A
DISADVANTAGE IN THE MARKETPLACE.
THE CBA POCKET WAIVER HAS WORKED
WELL FOR BOTH MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR, AS INDUSTRY GRIEVANCE
PROCEDURES PROVIDE AN EXPEDITED
PROCESS TO WORK THROUGH WORKER
GRIEVANCES THAT ARE TYPICALLY
RESOLVED WITHIN DAYS, WITH THE
WORKER RECEIVING 100% OF THE
RESTITUTION, AND THEN AS FINALLY
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED, AS IN ALL
CONSTRUCTION CBA CARVE OUTS IN
STATE LAW, THIS MEASURE DOES NOT
ALTER A LOCAL UNION'S ABILITY TO
INCLUDE OR NOT INCLUDE THE CARVE
OUT IN THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT. THAT
DECISION WOULD REMAIN SUBJECT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. SO FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS, WE WOULD URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO
YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS? YES
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON,
FOR TAKING ON THIS TASK. SENATOR
CORTEZ AS WELL, MADAM CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS, AS YOU HEARD, THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL TO EXTEND TO SUNSET.
SENATOR, HOW ARE YOU? IT DOES
REFLECT NINE DECADES OF PUBLIC
POLICY. WHEN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WAS ACTUALLY MADE
LEGAL. AND ENCOURAGED.
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS
ENCOURAGED BY THE LAW OF THE
LAND AS OF NINE DECADES AGO, AND
STILL IS TODAY. I'M GOING TO
KEEP THIS VERY BRIEF, BUT I ALSO
WANT TO ADD THE NATIONAL POLICY
HAS BEEN SINCE 1935 TO ALSO
ENCOURAGE ARBITRATION OVER
LITIGATION THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. BUT ARBITRATION
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES, BECAUSE
IT IS A PRIVATE SECTOR APPROACH
TO RESOLUTION OF DISPUTES. SO WE
ARE IN GOOD HANDS IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC POLICY. FOR ALMOST 100
YEARS, I ALSO WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT THAT THIS BILL IS NOT A
MANDATE. IT'S A PRIVATE SECTOR
RESOLUTION THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. NO UNION IS
OBLIGATED TO ADOPT THIS
EXEMPTION IF THEY DO NOT WISH TO
ADOPT THIS EXEMPTION. IT'S A
IT'S CHOSEN TO DO IT THROUGH THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. IT'S NOT
MANDATED. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TODAY'S ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS ARE TRAGICALLY
SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY WERE ALMOST
100 YEARS AGO. WHEN WE SEE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE STREETS,
WHEN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
BECAME A MANDATE. I'M SORRY, A
ENCOURAGED AND WORKERS WERE
GIVEN THE RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN. I'M NOT SURE WE'RE IN
THE SAME EXACT POSITION, BUT YOU
CAN SEE THE CHANGES UNTIL WE
HAVE A FAIRER ECONOMIC APPROACH
AND A WAY TO SOLVE PROBLEMS,
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN TROUBLE. SO
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO,
WHO WAS THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO ON THIS
BILL. AND IT'S A SIMPLE
EXTENSION OF A OF A SUNSET.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD, STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. MADAM
CHAIR JOE CRUZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
LABORERS, REPRESENTING 80,000
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY, A FEW
OF THOSE IN THE ROOM TODAY WERE
IN ORANGE AND OUTSIDE, WHO ARE
STRESSING THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. WE
WANT TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE FROM OUR INDUSTRY.
PARTNERS ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT PROCESS TO
RESOLVE RESOLUTIONS BOTH FOR THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE, WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIRMAN. I
WANT TO REMIND NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. MATT CREMEANS,
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. DOYLE
RADFORD, JUNIOR LABORERS, LOCAL
185. I'M THE BUSINESS MANAGER OF
THE MEN AND WOMEN HERE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN ORANGE.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
1034. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ADRIAN
ESPARZA. I'M THE BUSINESS
MANAGER FOR LABORERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF NORTH
AMERICA, LOCAL 652, IN ORANGE
COUNTY, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
1034. WE WISH YOUR VOTE ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. PAUL GLADFELTER, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS, WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. TODD
BLOOMSTEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
1034. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMAN,
FOR CARRYING THIS. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
RICK SMILES WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
LABORERS HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB 1034. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS BRETT BARROW WITH UNITED
CONTRACTORS AND WESTERN LINE
CONSTRUCTORS HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF 1034. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
LABORERS FROM THE CENTRAL COAST
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY, WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB 1034.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
NICK SANTOS AND I'M WITH
LABORERS, LOCAL 1309, COVERING
LONG BEACH AND SOUTH LA COUNTY
AREA. WE'RE HERE TO ECHO THAT.
WE'RE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
CHRIS WALKER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL AIR
CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. SCOTT.
GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. DAN BRANTON WITH THE
NORCAL CARPENTERS UNION. I'M A
SENIOR REPRESENTATIVE. MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OUT HERE
ALL WANTED TO DO ME TOO, BUT
THEY'VE ELECTED ME TO KIND OF
BRING FORTH THE MESSAGE WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. WILK WITH THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MY NAME IS THOMAS RUIZ,
REPRESENTATIVE FOR LABORERS
LOCAL 783 DOWN IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT OF 1034.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND MORE
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU. KEITH
DUNN, ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRONWORKERS IN
SUPPORT. HEY, IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT'S IT FOR SUPPORT. WE WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL? PLEASE COME HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE. SEEING NONE
ANY METOOS IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. OKAY. LOOKS LIKE NONE WILL
COME TO THE DAIS. ANY COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS? DO WE HAVE A.
WHENEVER SOMEBODY SAYS IT'S A
VERY SIMPLE BILL, I USUALLY
REREAD IT THREE TIMES TO MAKE
SURE. ESPECIALLY ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT'S MR. CURTIN, I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
THE GOOD SENATOR LAIRD, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE FIRST, MR.
GRAYSON? CHAIR, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. YOU. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION. A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LAIRD. ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB 1034. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SMALL CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
I WILK. WILK. AYE. CORTEZ. Â
CORTEZ. AYE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE
GREAT. THIS THIS BILL HAS A VOTE
OF 4 TO 0. IT IS ON CALL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. GRAYSON. THANK
YOU.
OKAY, ASSISTANT, LET'S OPEN THE
ROLL. LET'S SEE. WE HAVE. LET ME
GET MY LIST OUT. AB 224 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. WE HAD A
VOTE OF 4 TO 0. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB 224. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. I. OKAY. WITH A VOTE OF
5 TO 0, THAT BILL IS OUT. NEXT
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
1034. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
THAT WAS A 4 TO 0 VOTE ON FILE
ITEM TWO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. I OKAY. BILL. THE VOTE
OF 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY. THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
IS ADJOURNED.